uh but actually talking about starting
out amelia obviously your mother loves
you because you're her daughter yeah but
she is actually a sort of a fan as well
you know it's not it's not quite that
it's um
she is oh goodness right so
my uh uh
one day my mom came to set on the star
wars set uh and i was getting this thing
called cyber scand which is where you
stand in this kind of
loads of cameras and they kind of take
your form and put you into a computer
and make a toy or a
some sort of
merchandise or your face on a cushion
um and so
i go off and do this and i come back and
mom's like i've made a great friend and
i'm like brilliant it's lovely excellent
and she's like the merchandise you know
director of all of star wars or
something and i'm like wow
very impressive um and then before i
know it what comes in the post um is
loads of cushions
my face on it so
my own mum would guess she gets to see
it a fair amount you know but apparently
it's not enough so
i was kind of blown away how much
merchandise there is yes
i mean it's just the beginning it was
like the pre-merchandise not even the
real stuff is out yet and my mom has all
of it and doesn't know about the doll
yet so well this is so weird i don't
know is this in your flat or her house
okay so basically she'll be really funny
if i came home and it was everywhere in
my room
okay so this is this is this is amelia's
actual bedroom
[Laughter]
we found the photo but it's not like
that now
there is another reason why i'm saying
the first date back to that
i don't have a cv i just have a bedroom
but this is cool though so your mother a
big fan but brad pitt also a perfect fan
that was the best night of my life yes
tell the story quickly
yeah there's a duvet
uh no yeah there was this auction
thing that happened and um i don't they
called me and said would you you know do
you want to do you want to um auction
something off like maybe sort of an
experience watching the show with you or
something and i was like okay it's
lovely it's great for charity yeah it'll
be for some you know some something yeah
and it'll be fine anyway so i get there
and it's amazing it'll be a good thing
um i get there and it's basically like
this basically it's the oscars there's
so many celebrities in this room and i
suddenly remember that i said that i
would auction something off and so the
fear grows
so i was petrified absolutely petrified
and then um the the person whose table i
was on is a friend and he was being very
kind and kind of put the paddle up and i
was like thanks very much that's very
sweet there'll be that
and then someone else's paddle up went
up across the other side of the room and
i didn't really know and then suddenly
it was sort of becoming a bit of money
and i was kind of thinking oh this is
absolutely mental and someone went it's
brad pitt and i was like oh
sure
yeah exactly
and i look over to the room and he's got
his paddle up brad's paddle that has
brown
no
not quite well it didn't work out
because the person whose friend who was
my friend i think was probably all set
up personally who was my friend ended up
you know doing the highest bid but
but uh yeah i just kind of looked over
with just the most insane emoji heart
eyes being like this is just the
greatest moment of my life
[Music]
you